grâce à certaines sources nous savons
aujourd'hui que les états unis
conduisent une opération top secrète
ici dans le désert qui se trouve
derrière moi est loin d'être terminée
qu'est ce qu'il veut il a fabriqué un
très grand nombre de bombes sales si on
remporte pas la victoire
nour a fait tout ça pour rien je demande
qu'on envoie des drones predator dans la
zone
si jamais les choses devaient tourner au
vinaigre on leur enverra un missile
halfaya vous y allez vous le trouvez
vous des lignes on entrera par la grande
porte gars
ils sont trop nombreux couvre mois
je vous nous allons reprendre nos têtes
j'ai les banques officiel
pour dégager cible localiser
vous avez mon feu vert quand
annette
on dégage dégage